Die Wunderwelt von Bruno Weber –
kaum vorstellbar,
dass man hier mitten in der Schweiz ist.
Fast fünfzig Jahre lang
hat der Künstler einen Ort geschaffen,
der seiner Vorstellungskraft entsprungen ist.
Fantasiekreaturen und Fabelwesen
gibt es hier an allen Ecken.
Mit seiner Frau Maria Anna Weber
lebte er hier bis zu seinem Tod 2011.
Sie weiß, was ihn zu
dieser verrückten Anlage inspiriert hat.
Märchen und Mythen
hatten ganz sicher einen Einfluss.
Wir lasen uns auch immer
wieder vor, vor dem Einschlafen.
Er liebte sakrale Orte,
vor allem gotische Kathedralen.
Er hat immer wieder
dann aus dem Eigenen geschöpft,
es gibt Mappen voll[er] Ideen,
die er gern noch ausgeführt hätte.
Bruno Weber war Maler,
Architekt und Bildhauer zugleich,
er lebte in und mit seiner Kunst.
Seine Frau Maria Anna Weber hat all die
Jahre an seinem Werk mitgearbeitet.
Sie hat Betonfiguren gegossen,
was sie heute noch mit ihrem Enkel macht,
Mosaike gelegt und zeigt auch immer
noch Park und Wohnhaus den Besuchern.
Ich zeige euch ’s Haus, kommt mit rein.
Ja, ich möchte euch hier
den Waldgarten zeigen,
den Bruno symbolisch
als Raum dargestellt hat.
Ihr seht hier die Tiere
des Waldes quasi umgesetzt,
die Sträucher, das Feuer,
das man sich im Wald macht.
Und da sieht man die Skulptur, die das
Menschliche und Tierische vereinbart
und gleichzeitig der Geschirrschrank ist.
Gegessen wird hier entweder am Tischgrill
oder am transparenten Schmetterlingstisch
mit geflügelten Stühlen.
Hier gibt es überall Wege
und Durchgänge zum Entdecken.
Im ersten Stock:
das Familienbadezimmer, wie eine
Tropfsteinhöhle mit bunten Edelsteinen.
Die riesige Badewanne
war vor allem ein großer Spaß
für die Zwillingstöchter der Webers.
Heute ist sie den Enkeln
und der Enkelin vorbehalten.
Dieser(n) Raum mit den vielen Stalaktiten
empfinde ich so als Mosaikorgie.
Das Schlafzimmer gleich nebenan:
fröhlich und positiv.
Wir kommen da ins Blätterzimmer.
Da ist die Sonne,
und im Frühling scheint sie direkt
aufs Bett, also die Sonne durch die Sonne
durch das Tiffany-Glas.
Ein Stockwerk weiter oben
wartet die nächste Überraschung.
Hier kommt man in das Sternenzimmer,
ein ganz besonderer Rückzugsort
auf achteckigem Grundriss
mit direktem Blick in den Himmel.
Bruno hatte hier seinen Tisch, Stuhl,
zeichnete, machte Entwürfe, las –
was auch immer, so dass er ungestört war.
Bis hier rauf durften die Besucher nicht.
Dieser Raum wurde auch benützt für Feste,
eine Trauung, es war der Raum für Silvester.
Im Park von Bruno Weber dreht sich alles um
grenzenlose Fantasie und Vorstellungskraft.
Und am Ende ist es fast seltsam zu sehen,
dass die normale Schweizer Welt mit
ihren Fabriken und Schornsteinen
direkt vor der Haustür liegt.